in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we take a look at big tables
monitoring UI to find out our
performance edge cases will we scale to
meet the challenge stay tuned to find
out when you're dealing with something
at the scale of big table performance is
always on your mind a big tables ability
to handle billion user systems happens
almost entirely behind the scenes where
front-ends can coordinate balance and
optimize your access patterns without
you having to lift a finger but even the
best systems need a little attention now
in that thankfully the monitoring UI is
here to help the big table UI in the
cloud console has a built-in monitoring
tool that automatically reports how your
nodes clusters and instances are
performing showing things like CPU
utilization error rate and storage
utilization all in a handy graph form so
that at a glance you can see how your
systems have been performing and while
having this graph data is great what's
really important is finding the
situations where it actually tells you
something here's a few common use cases
that are worth keeping an eye on as
mentioned before BigTable works by
keeping a set of front-end nodes which
are responsible for routing and
balancing traffic to the back end tables
when you create your BigTable instance
you specify the number of nodes you want
and using the monitoring tool you can
quickly see if it's time to add more
notes on our instances tab we can take a
look at the CPU utilization table which
has a recommended max line this line
represents the best practices for CPU
utilization and if you eclipse this line
for a number of minutes it's generally a
good idea to add more nodes to your
cluster now another common performance
problem with BigTable is asymmetric
reads and writes on a cluster for
example suppose that 25% of your reads
are going to a small number of tablets
within a cluster while the rest are
spread evenly across the other tablets
when BigTable detects this happening it
will redistribute the existing tablets
so that reads are spread as evenly as
possible across the entire cluster now
we can detect this pattern in the
monitoring tool by keeping an eye on the
CPU utilization of the hottest node
graph it's a lot of air quotes
if the hottest node is frequently above
the recommended value even when your
average CPU utilization is reasonable
then you'll need to go back and check
your schema design to up
your access patterns accordingly now if
you want to drill deeper into your
schema design challenges then you might
want to take a look at the key
visualizer tool which provides a really
fancy heat map visualizer that can help
you figure out where your schema design
might be going off the rails but that's
a topic for another episode if you're
interested no more then check out the
article linked in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe to our
YouTube cloud channel for other great
performance Atlas content because when
it comes to performance every
millisecond counts